[Musique]
la prière anti Poutine des poussières se
trouvait un nouvel écho avec la guerre
en Ukraine ces activistes russes ont
choisis un lieu symbolique de la
capitale pour donner de la voix la
grande cathédrale orthodoxe du quai
Branly qui dépend directement de
l'ambassade de Russie
beaucoup de gens pensent que les Russes
sont pour la guerre mais c'est faux ils
sont nombreux à s'y opposer nous voulons
le dire ouvertement là où c'est encore
possible car ce n'est malheureusement
plus le cas en Russie aujourd'hui
je veux que Poutine soit jugé que ses
crimes soient portés à la connaissance
du monde entier pour que son régime
s'écroule définitivement le plus vite
possible
en juin dernier si Eva ne pensait pas
s'installer en France mais depuis la
mobilisation annoncée par Vladimir
Poutine il craint d'être envoyé de force
en Ukraine
mobilisation est une catastrophe ce
qu'ils disent à la télé qu'il ne s'agit
que de 300 000 réservistes qualifiés
c'est un mensonge total ils prennent les
gens sans distinction des étudiants des
scientifiques je suis personnellement
concerné car je suis moi-même réserviste
un autre groupe de militants russes est
invité ce jour-là dans le centre de
Paris
elles ont choisi la couleur du deuil
pour marquer les esprits
et antiger
nous sommes les soeurs les veuves et les
épouses de ce pays qui tuent ses propres
enfants et ceux des autres
de nombreux artistes et intellectuels
russes ont choisi l'exil depuis le début
du conflit arrivé en France en mars
dernier d'achat est illustratrice elle
s'engage contre la guerre et la censure
d'État à travers son travail
et je fais une série qui représente pour
moi la protestation telle qu'elle existe
là en ce moment dans mon pays c'est pour
montrer que la protestation est
complètement étouffée que que les gens
qui restent là-bas et même qui sont
contre ils sont un peu comme ces animaux
pendus
tué par notre pouvoir
maintenant c'est impossible d'être
artiste et de pouvoir
s'exprimer j'ai mes amis artistes mes
profs qui sont là-bas et qui je vois à
quel point il souffre mais peuvent
quasiment rien dire sinon il
recourt à la périphrase presque honteuse
d'achat enseigner aussi le français en
Russie elle a tout laissé derrière elle
pour s'installer en banlieue parisienne
et vient d'obtenir l'asile politique le
vanca février quand j'ai appris que la
Russie avait attaqué l'Ukraine
je suis devenue
vraiment folle je connais beaucoup
d'artistes craignants à tes amis quand
qui se font bombarder par par tes
compatriotes tu sais pas quoi leur dire
c'est juste c'est une honte et horrible
c'est dans l'Est de la France qu'endray
a posé ses valises il y a quelques mois
ce brillant chercheur en mathématiques
et en philosophie a obtenu un poste à
l'université de Nancy il fait partie de
cette élite intellectuelle russe souvent
issue des grandes villes qui a émigré en
masse après l'invasion de l'Ukraine
si vous n'êtes pas en prison vous êtes
considéré comme un membre du camp des
méchants qui livre une guerre
d'agression et
je ne voulais absolument pas me
retrouver dans cette situation
alors je n'ai pas hésité un seul instant
nous retrouvons André chez lui avec son
épouse marina et leurs deux filles ce
couple d'universitaire a abandonné une
situation confortable à
Saint-Pétersbourg
pour moi aller au travail était comme un
combat quotidien
je devais soit défendre mon point de vue
soit sourire et continuer à travailler
c'est très difficile de respirer le même
air que ceux qui sont pour la mort
le plus important aujourd'hui c'est bien
sûr cette guerre
contre l'Ukraine
il fallait choisir son camp et partir
était une manière de le faire
l'exil de Marina et Andreï s'inscrit
dans cette fuite des cerveaux qui frappe
la Russie depuis le 24 février à cela
s'ajoute le récent exode massif qui a
suivi la mobilisation partielle d'après
le journal Novaya Gazeta plus de 260 000
russes ont fui leur pays depuis le 21
septembre dernier